listen gods anybody in the reject nation
wants to do a Kickstarter program to
make a chud movie but I say let's make a
chud movie they a bunch of people are
gonna say yeah he's right let's do that
oh I'll start the Kickstarter thing and
whatever and GoFundMe page four I'll put
it at the very beginning of this video
then you don't think I don't know why
you're not doing more acting do you ever
just look at your IMDB all the time
lookit look at all I have a conflation
this will get cut out there it is I'm
only keeping the dead space in this
video
alright neutronic hey guys so I started
editing this video from 2af till about
717 a.m. I've had so much fun editing
this video this is an interview with
oscar-winning makeup artist Joel Harlow
makeup artist makeup effects designer
the department head he's worked with
some of the biggest directors in
Hollywood today like Christopher Nolan
JJ Abrams Ryan Coogler just a few of his
credits include Logan black panther the
parts of the Caribbean franchise the
most recent Hellboy the upcoming
Godzilla king of monsters there's a
whole lot we talked about in this
interview it's honestly just so much fun
we talked for well over an hour
I trimmed it down to just my favorite
parts even if you're not really into
listening to makeup effects talk it's
not only that that we do here it's just
a really fun conversation a lot of
laughs to be had and a lot of really
cool insight wish I could just keep the
whole thing in here but of course I'm
gonna tighten it up I wanted to thank a
man named Luis Lopez because we recorded
this were the new mics we bought so we
could have better audio but for some
reason my mic input volume was insanely
high so it's not a very blown out and
Luis Lopez managed to fix
thing to everyone else said was
impossible to fix so thank you Luis for
that got that hook up through our friend
Eric Newark Roenick and the other thing
is I put out our community page that I'm
gonna be having Joel Harlow come on the
channel to submit some questions so he
does answer some of your guys's
questions really in-depth load of you
guys to share this this one means a lot
to me and overall I hope you all enjoy
you have a good day hello nation my name
is Greg album with me I have Joe Harlow
I'm laughing right now because I'm
surrounded by a whole bunch of boxes the
day I decided to bring Joel over box you
move to help me move yeah I want to come
on and promote to talk about Hellboy or
whatever I just need help moving Joe
help me to the van with somebody's bomb
fine if you guys are know Joe Harlow he
is a makeup effects artist what are all
the titles you have yeah makeup artist
makeup effects designer makeup designer
department head balm and you were the
main one for the gosh that's right I did
catch your little cameo and Hellboy I
did Aaron stood my girl for a living
that's Joel he's worked on so many films
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise your
foot giant Depp quite a bit yeah Black
Panther main makeup artist there yeah
Hellboy the most recent one obviously
I'm just looking at it to all the Star
Trek films you won an Oscar for the
first Star Trek yeah yeah the first JJ
Abrams Star Trek which was a great
speech you gave by the way I watched the
video before you came over wonderful
words of wisdom you talk amongst
yourselves like the people that are
nominated you talk amongst yourselves
you decide who's going to actually speak
because they give you a you know and you
go to the Academy lunch and they're like
okay we want to make this as interesting
and as quick as possible right you know
so that people don't tune out in the
middle of it we decided that Mindy who
was the department head on the fact
gotcha
are you sure you weren't really upset
that you didn't get to speak at the
Oscars because that would make for some
great clickbait right now yes at some
point you maybe get that
yeah I mean will you've been nominated a
few more times since then but more
importantly you are now in Gregg's
two-bedroom apartment yeah on the
YouTube channel the real rejects yep
so I think it's about time you call mom
and dad I finally made it in Hollywood
that weird dream I had when I was a kid
I finally made it
here's a gift bag I get to take when I
leave here that only the parts that make
you look bad I'm gonna keep it parts
that make you look bad so I know Joel
threw his stepdaughter Ashley ho who
I've been friends with for like I don't
know I've known ever since I was like 14
years old we've talked quite a bit we've
had a lot of long conversations back and
forth and yet I felt weirdly nervous
about having you come on
but today yeah but then he goes to the
boxes it's and it's for Joel Harlow man
and then I decided to look up your
interviews on YouTube I was like oh
you're only highest you'd interview as
one point 6 K views so I'm good that's
good but I think if I can if I can beat
that then you'll be sending me a hank
knowledge that I know John from way back
Scott Ian's blood and guts at the fish
man thing yeah yeah yeah you guys
snapchat each other back so forth a lot
all right now we have a bunch of fan
questions I put out a post saying I have
Joel coming on who whoever has questions
go ahead submit some questions here so
it's gonna be a variety me asking some
questions and then going to what you
guys wanted to ask Joel yourself so my
first question for Joel has anyone ever
told you that you could be the third
brother to the Will Ferrell Chad Smith
from Red Hot Chili Peppers
I just got out of the shower and all the
water is leaking on my forehead right
now so how boy just came out and and I
did want to ask I know that one that
first trailer debut there was a big
backlash that happened in terms of the
makeup actually in you and I talk back
and forth I can't be too much of a you
know optimistic feeling to have but
funny enough with the film coming out
the most common thing I'm hearing from
all across the board even with critics
so I know that didn't necessarily
recommend the movie a lot of them are
still saying the practical effects and
the makeup are great in the film so how
does that make you feel you know in the
first trailer come out I think that when
you make a movie like this when you when
you embark on this path that isn't but
is following in the footsteps of two
beautiful films that came before it yeah
more del Toro's films I mean all of
Guillermo s films are beautiful you know
that you're gonna be up against it
you're going to take a lot of heat there
are those fans that are you know
fiercely loyal to those films of course
fiercely loyal to Ron Perlman who is an
amazing actor as Hellboy honestly I'm
one of those guys I'm one of those guys
was it hard getting that out of your
head when you were it is it's like you
know I'd look to those films and that
work you know many times throughout my
career and you know just you really
admired you know the artistry that went
into not only the makeups but the films
themselves so you know you're gonna be
up against it's poppers I think that you
know wisely all of us in the shop when
we took this on made a conscious effort
not to reference those films they are
beautiful in their own right they stand
alone very d'amour oh yeah you know I'm
a huge fan this wasn't one of those
films this is a different film and the
way that we kind of approached it was
that it was sort of an 80s monster movie
it was guys and makeups guys and suits
really just beating the hell out of each
other and that's so like when the first
trailer came out it didn't really convey
the movie that I know
we made which was you know pretty hard
are where I always a hard it was a
violent monster brawl and it didn't
really convey that so I don't think that
it gave the viewers a lot to go on
other than a comparison to the other
movies fair and they're comparing the
other movies and obviously they're
comparing you know our to hell boys I
think in time it will become its own
sort of cult classic yeah I kind of view
it as sort of like army of Darkness yeah
you know cuz there's like Evil Dead
wanted to and army of darkness and then
I also kind of think of there's been a
several adaptations of the the Marvel
character The Punisher and this is kind
of like The Punisher war zone the second
one that came yeah like that's sort of
what I viewed this one could actually
have in terms of a following over time
it's a fun movie if you go to this film
go in you know with an 80s sensibility
you know any Tony's ability you know
before everything kind of got watered
down by the you know the the sensors and
you know this is you know it's like go
to your video store pick up you know
videotape pop it in and like watch some
like gory effects and guys in suits back
when things were done primarily
practical right right you know and there
wasn't a lot of digital this however has
both I mean it does have a lot of
digital you know some sequences better
than others but all in all it's it's a
fun damn movie it's good if this is your
kind of movie it's not a critics movie
it's an audience movie for sure and I
feel like that's where a lot of the
support has been coming in that's why in
my review I specifically pointed out on
Rotten Tomatoes that it was fresh on the
audience cool yeah because to me it's
kind of more worrisome one in when the
critic score is high with the audience
scores left that's actually a better
sign there's more people chiming and out
there I mean and I've you know I've
worked on films that have been panned by
critics before you know which film this
one asked which film that was panned by
critics do you personally think is like
a great movie lone ranger lone ranger
hands down Lone Ranger I think is a
beautiful friggin movie Tarantino
actually put that on one of his top ten
movies about your Christmas we're out to
get it from day one and you know what
Zukowski says about critics critics are
parasites who absolutely know nothing
about art I've got that quote
on my phone but what critics like your
movie are you happy you know what you
can't really you know if you're gonna
let somebody else tell you what you're
going to think then grow a pair man and
and just being a frickin sheep and make
up your own mind make up your own go and
if you don't like it you don't like it
you know but nowadays everybody's a
critic
you know because of social media anybody
can jump on lines and there's a lot of
Twitter critics out there you know
nobody cares nobody cares yeah don't
watch my reviews either guys you know
critics do like your film because you
know ultimately what it means is that
you know more of the general audience
will go to see it because I there are a
lot of people that you know they have
their certain critics that they follow
if this guy likes this or this girl
likes this then you know that's my
sensibility so I'll go see whatever they
say all I'm saying is just make up your
own mind
is there a director you really would
like to work with I'm going off the top
of my head here cuz he showed up early
which threw off my whole game everyone's
always like like five minutes
showed up nine minutes early I'm gonna
be mentally prepared for directors you
worked with you worked on inception
right yep inception Stuart granola and
gore verbinski it's too many directors
count right now is there a specific
director that you would absolutely love
to work I know you mean I know del Toro
seem to have a very specific crew he
works with yeah unfortunately for me
that's the one okay well he's a huge fan
of this channel yeah oh yeah he loves
reaction channels so oh yeah he's gonna
watch it there's a documentary called
Lovecraft fear of the unknown
he's prominently featured in whenever I
sit down to sculpt something and I
sculpt a lot of Lovecraft inspired
pieces for myself I'll put on that
documentary and just listen to him and
talk about you know his views on
Lovecraft and his interpreter awesome
Lovecraft you still listen up there like
for myself like I like to write and
everything it's all sometimes like just
listen to Tarantino while I'm cleaning
or something like that so you'll still
do that even while you're creating yeah
also put on you know a lot of books on
tape primarily you know Lovecraft
stories that all play awesome you know
you've gone so far in this business and
you hear Const like for this year alone
you've had yet how about that just came
out Godzilla king of monsters yep which
looks [ __ ] awesome [ __ ] great what
was that exact thing you do because the
makeup department so you still work on
the monster designs and stuff no no no
on that one I didn't which you know for
me was a drag because I'd been a
Godzilla fan yeah and so I was a kid
ever since my dad took me you know one
of the first movies I remember seeing
saw a double feature in Pueblo Colorado
in the first film actually they're my
two biggest inspirations Godzilla and
Lovecraft but the first film was die
monster die Boris Karloff okay okay it
was based on the color out of space
Lovecraft story followed by destroy all
monsters Wow which is now you get to
work on none of those guys that's true
so if you were to venture off into
directing and you were to take on a
Godzilla film would you bring it back I
mean look at the look at the roland
emmerich Godzilla
yes Patrick Tatopoulos design Godzilla
ooh a lot of people have problems with
but again if you take it as its own
movie you know and maybe you know take
the Godzilla name out of it it becomes
less of a problem but the cool thing
about that is they built like whatever
it was a quarter scale Godzilla
yeah built a city they member that
behind the scenes you know guys there
was guys in suits insert pieces you know
it's like with anime
Onix being what they are now I think it
would be really cool to see a Godzilla
movie done that way rather than just
okay let's just you know the monsters
all gonna be digital it looks great it
looks amazing
ultimately if the story's good enough
it's gonna suck you in doesn't matter
because of what I do I prefer practical
you know and I think that you know it'd
be cool to make a Godzilla suit or hmm
Mechagodzilla suit or whatever I mean I
stopped when I was a kid but I lost it
in the Northridge earthquake Oh is there
a comic book movie you would love to
actually I'm when I stopped by her shop
I was trying to get a sense for his
lifestyle when he's not working and then
I realize all he ever does is create
just like like do you meditate or
anything no I just keep creating that is
your version of meditation as your bird
like some therapeutic type of treatment
for it it's like you have a way of
making your money doing this but then
you also still hone in on that passion
and fun you were showing me that you
were working on some design from just a
Judge Dredd comic books and your
fascination if I'm not mistaken you
you're fascinated with anatomy and fish
going back to you were asking if there
was a comic book yeah you know what
character or a comic book movie yeah I
mean it's been made twice the Judge
Dredd has been made twice once not so
great but had some really cool stuff in
it like the angel family and I'm talking
about the Stallone version the angel
family was amazing Mean Machine
beautiful oh yeah yeah then Dredd you
know with Karl Urban yeah Judge Dredd
who I think did an incredible job never
took the helmet off yeah which is what
you want in your judges choice right
yeah and the movie itself that's one of
those that also put on and just under
rated should have been a bigger box ah
yes yeah yeah and we could maybe get a
sequel where we would be introduced to
the dark judges judge death fear right
mortis and fire I think I told you this
actually I think it would be cool if you
did the attack on Titan
designs that would because they're doing
a live-action one and I think yeah yeah
I know they did one they did a little
for Japan they did but but in the states
I think is the director of
it and a machete I think he's doing in
any machetes a big fan of this channel
just like your oh I can't tell if you're
being sincere I don't think anyone I'm
always surprised when someone even for
like people who worked on Hellboy who
commented on our trailer reaction I was
like someone from the studio notices or
director notices bunch of guys to bid on
something and then you know whichever
designs we like the best and come in the
cheapest then we'll go with that guy but
occasionally I mean I do have friends
who are directors producers who are
friends a variety of folks that you know
when they get something that involves
work you know the kind of work that I do
that they'll you know bring enormous ly
grateful to zoom in on get to those fan
questions John do you have any selected
nerd chronics named Erik he's great
editor this guy follow this YouTube
channel actually Logan Logan
look you didn't see the black and white
version did you know I didn't know it's
so much better I don't like seeing the
make up in colors it just ruins the film
for me Logan takes a more grounded
approach to the comic book John rrah
what challenges or opportunities arose
when working on a project that require
more subtlety and realism than its
sister films question anytime you do
something I mean you know comic book or
not or not that replicates reality it's
infinitely more difficult and and more
challenging than you know say say a
fantasy film because on a fantasy film
if you're creating a fantasy character
it's like you've got a lot of leeway
there you know say you're doing a nail
whatever Star Trek alien nobody's ever
seen that alien before so you've got a
lot of room to maneuver but if you're
doing something realistic you know
people have seen you know have seen us
they say you're doing an old-age makeup
people see you know old people all the
time you know so that kind of work
becomes more challenging because you're
replicating you know real-life
characters a real-life looks it's
actually less of a challenge to create
something completely sci-fi completely
out of this world that it is to
replicate let's say like what they did
with Christian Bale advisors yeah it's a
different kind of challenge I mean I
wouldn't say it's less of a challenge I
mean certainly on Hellboy there were
easy main challenges a lot of different
challenges you know when you're creating
a fantasy character you want it to look
real you want Claudius to believe it as
a character but you know if you have to
put a wrinkle somewhere or you want it
you know you want to change bone
structure you can do that because it is
a fantasy character reality is is much
less forgiving I wouldn't say it's it's
more challenging let's just say it's
much much less forgiving because it is
so commonplace of course so if you're
you know like black mass you know Whitey
Bulger character Johnny Denton that was
a subtle makeup you know it was
basically a forehead piece came up to
the crown that had punched hair in it
punched eyebrows in that yeah and and we
were replicating a version of a real
person we weren't going one-to-one
likeness but we were you know we were
hitting sort of the notes of the
likeness so that there was enough there
for you to buy into I'm you know you
know a lot of people didn't know who
James Whitey Bulger was every day folks
might not know what he looks like so he
was my role model doing doing a
one-to-one likeness wasn't necessary but
you know having those you know sort of
notes of the likeness watch Johnny Depp
does seem like one of those guys who
does he ever lost say and what goes on
with the makeup cause you guys have
collaborated so often it is he seems
like you really
the body language yeah he's an amazing
amazing guy and he knows how to use the
tricks of the business whether it's
makeup hair props wardrobe environment
does he like come to you and say this is
what I want because there are movies
where you didn't you weren't the makeup
artist for it but you were just his
makeup artist according to your IMDB
like me yes yeah I mean he had sketched
out sometimes no I mean he's he knows
the language of makeup so often with
other actors or is that that's very rare
Wow very rare that's really cool yeah no
he got a full knowledge of you know all
the elements that it takes to create a
character and he uses them beautifully
and in coordination with each other you
know to create a character that's
believable as he has beautiful in real
life as yeah yeah I mean he's got the
biggest heart in the world yeah yeah can
I have five dollars Joel I'm helping you
yeah of course of course 20 dollars for
four hours that was just one Jay Scavo
Rhea what emerging tech is he he is
capital H meaning Joel excited to
experiment with and incorporate into
your next project what are you currently
are currently working on Jungle Cruise
is the one right yeah yeah we're doing
some additional photography it so it's a
film that we shot primarily last year
okay we're doing some you know as you
always do
you know when you shoot one of these big
films is you come back for reshoots you
know there's a rough cut and you come
back and whatever the media outlets here
there's a reshoot that means the film is
in trouble
but yeah what emerging tech is it oh you
can think of no I mean there's nothing
really I can think of because you know
all the materials and techniques that we
use you know fortunately I work
with an amazing group of artists and
technicians and we're all up on you know
the latest materials and the latest
techniques and the latest processes you
know that are coming up I mean you know
these are cutting-edge guys there's
nothing I can really put my finger on
as far as as a emerging tech well you
know I think maybe we're Jay Scott for
real is going with this sort of the
combination of digital and practical
make them let's just be kind of thinking
the digital and the practical there's
always ideally there's a marriage
between the two
you know because makeup is additive of
course it's like anytime you put a
makeup on its increasing size it's
increasing bulk you can design a makeup
you know to look like it's diminishing
bulk you know like a zombie appliance
for example you bring out the cheekbones
bring out the brow bone you know bone
and by comparison everything else is you
know sunken in that's not what is
actually happening what you're doing is
you're you're increasing bulk on those
areas that you brought forward say like
of all the mess a Baltimore missing his
nose how do you do that in the real
world well you really can't you try to
tape somebody's nose down that's gonna
get incredibly uncomfortable after
coming in so you do the makeup around
the area that then digitally will be
removed you know somebody with half
their head gone that combination of
practical and digital is I think you
know where you want to land as an artist
because there was a huge pendulum swing
it's like you know back in whatever in
the 80s early 90s it was all practical
yeah and we swung to you know digital
was it American Werewolf in Paris and
then you know the pendulum swing is
gradually coming back where is now you
know people are appreciating the
practical more and directors are
appreciating the practical more because
it's infinitely more impressive to come
walking out on set dressed up like you
know
Hellboy beast of the Apocalypse of
course then you know David Harbor in a
you know leotard would box and it gives
your other actors something to play off
sure can light him in the environment
that he's supposed to be
I remember that time when everyone's
just like I'm so sick of all this
overblown CGI and now there seems to be
more of a marriage happening between the
two you don't seem opposed against that
you know it's its own art form you know
and maybe this was true a few years back
is I would sit in meetings where the
digital folks would be hungry to get
characters or to get sequences and just
you know marginalize the practical but I
think if you and this goes to all of you
filmmakers out there I love you you know
up-and-coming filmmakers get as much in
camera as possible because you can
always go back digitally augment or you
know digitally correct or whatever it is
I mean I would rather get an entire
character in camera that maybe has a
tear in the shoulder go back and fix
that as opposed to completely create the
character from scratch digitally you
know without the time or the money to do
it and wind up looking like a cartoon
you know what I mean because I've seen a
lot of digital it just looks like looks
like Frank cartoons it's like no matter
you know no matter how good the movie is
it's like I it's distracting yeah what
am i watching and you see something
practical you know it exists in the real
world and there's something about that
even if it doesn't look as polished or
slick even if you know it I haven't
mentioned it to you personally but that
Baba Yaga was that's actually a thing
I'm here not a lot of people talk about
you're on a film like Hellboy there's a
lot of sort of organizational stuff that
I end up having to do getting my hands
in the clay in the shop is much more
difficult than on a smaller show
certainly when I'm on set I'll get my
hands in the application stuff but Baba
Yaga was the character that I sculpted
myself that's the one that I because a
shot at the end of the schedule we shot
in Bulgaria so I had you know I would do
the Hellboy makeup in the morning and
Heather mages who helped me with that
makeup she would watch David on set I
met her and I would go back and I would
sculpt Baba Yaga with the help of Josh
McCarran who was with me he sculpted the
hands which are friggin beautiful pretty
scary yeah it's really scary yeah
door James did a great job found him on
the Internet
miss Detroit you know I was like that
guy's amazing it's like I want him to
play Baba Yaga unfortunately you know
the producers gave me a lot of freedom
on Hellboy can't play Abe Sapien sure
thanks Joel let's see her too here big
casting announcement yes so she's cast
herself as Hellboy yeah make up to
yourself would you do make up for any of
our sketches yeah yeah
sketches what are you talking about you
do sketches like skits Joel's a huge fan
of the channel Fernandez what was the
biggest problem he had while working
with Davy Jones and his crew well
obviously talking about pirates two and
three Davy Jones is digital entirely
digital so you had no problems bootstrap
bill however is entirely practical oh
cool one of my favorite all-time
answering Pablo's question ideally I
think that it would have been cool to do
more of the Davy Jones crew as practical
makeups would have been crazy truthfully
at that time doing bootstrap because the
undergoes like you know six different
stages it's sort of a transformation
like a degenerative transformation as he
gets absorbed into the flying dutchman
that was a lot of work of course there's
a lot of work designed by crash McCreary
beautiful
illustrator and conceptual designer
worked for Stan Winston for you know a
lot of his career now works I think
mostly with core you know design drengo
and oh yeah just an amazing designer so
to be able to take his illustrations and
translate
on the Stellan you know I was a blast
can I do my my terrible job for you it
yeah my terrible giant every alright can
you haven't heard it yet right no it's
making made waves on Johnny alright I'm
gonna I'll do one line for you this is
this is how I always imagined giant up
in interviews it always seems like he's
gonna say something really deep but then
he doesn't so here it goes when I first
read the screenplay for um
Rango half way through the script I
realized I'm playing a lizard and from
there that character just sort of
evolved yeah that's about it a few
awkward moments just for him today
you're like you're injecting those on
purpose it was an awkward up until that
I know it's like thirty minutes into
this I'm like I need something good
transition with cringe gaming how is the
harsh reality for all people who want to
get jobs in the film industry and how
does race or ethnicity factor into that
like say if if an Indian wants that act
or do makeup jobs does that affect I
feel like you know behind the scenes
yeah I mean especially yeah where your
some of your people who you're currently
work with and wide variety is exactly
you know we're not looking at at race or
ethnicity we're not looking for diplomas
or degrees because this is visual medium
what I do is a visual medium we're
looking at portfolios of course for me
that doesn't factor into my hiring
process whatsoever the only advice that
I could give would be just to practice
your art practice your techniques hone
your skills and you know that's that's
what we look at you know because
ultimately we're not the ones you know
up on screen unless you cast yourself as
Klaus of Verner von crop
I did doesn't matter at all I mean if I
were to answers I would say be white
okay cringe gaming be white I think Joe
will back me up on this people based on
and you know if I'm able to cast people
based on their abilities you know and
same with the hiring process in the shop
so that's awesome yeah actually if
someone in your shop watch a genuine one
someone in your shop does watch a
channel whoo-hoo that makes me look bad
I know remember is no Johnny Johnny
Johnny psycho Johnny psycho is his name
yeah that's the one guy Johnny psycho
all right we got one more question one
more question
rephrasing fundies question what's
something that you've sort of had to
struggle with but that you feel like
ended up being one of your proudest
accomplishments yeah yeah I mean I
that's really hard to answer because I
think that if you don't struggle with
each project and it comes too easily
it's it's almost not worth it Oh
interesting it's like an actually unique
challenge yeah that goes for like
personal projects as well it's like if I
sit down in front and let's say I sit
down in front of a live cast and I'm
gonna sculpt something like I just
sculpted this chud character for a trade
show if it comes to easy sometimes I
just won't finish it you know like the
shapes you know it emerges too quickly
there's something about struggling with
the clay struggling with the forms and
the character of the piece that when you
find it it's infinitely more rewarding
anxiety in that problem yeah I can't
find it I'm like you know it's like what
should I do and I'll put it aside and
I'll start something else but that's
always like you know it's like over here
staring at me
I'm like I gotta get back to it mind it
and until I find it you know I'm very
unsettled have you ever felt like
leaving a project like what's something
I bet yeah something you been attached
to you know the only the only times that
I've had to leave projects was when you
know I usually get contracted for
something and then sometimes things go
longer than they were supposed to and
we're committed to something else
something else gets pushed up it's like
then it you know it it's an unfortunate
thing but hopefully you've got a team
around you and since I'm typically the
department head you know I'll have like
Mikey take over or whatever you know
finish up this while I start on that
yeah I don't I don't like to finish or
to leave things unfinished I don't like
to finish anything I wish that a problem
you know it's been so many things so
many jobs that I wish could have just
kept going I mean Hellboy was one of
those you know that I wish could have
just kept going and going and going
because I was having so much fun I mean
Hellboy it's like that's something that
I'd wanted to do make monsters yeah you
know that's why I got into this business
you know Star Trek beyond that's why I
got into this business
pirates whatever because I want to make
monsters I want to create characters of
course and then when it's over it's like
it leaves you kind of you know searching
for something to do like I like I just
mentioned I finished this chud character
and now I went to the shop today to drop
some stuff off before I came over here
and there's really nothing on my plate
that's pressing right now you know I've
got these reshoots coming up but you
know there's not a whole lot for me to
to build I'll send you concept art for
our puppets show that we have here we
can make for like 20 grand you can since
I don't watch it I'm not sure you can
now yeah I mean I've got all the stuff
it's like I think it'd be you know I
don't know why they haven't made chud
again well you haven't directed it
that's why well I mean I don't even need
to direct I just want it's like I just I
just want to make just right so why not
turn the monster
like a Kickstarter thing it's like
people have made movies for less less
than you know what a couple hundred
grand yeah and you get from those
Kickstarter's like listen buddy in the
reject nation wants to do a Kickstarter
program to make a chud movie I don't
know who's got the rights to Chuck John
can you look that up real quick like
John Deere Joe wants to make a chud
movie I've already got the Chuck I'll
send you a picture and you can put it up
right now like at this point in the
video after you alright this part in I'm
sure I think you should really cut out
any of this except for the part where
you do your Johnny Depp no there should
be the opening how about we call it
something other than shut oh you're
looking at me for this answer because it
came out really cool cool it's done
we've got a choice we can work on it we
can just make more did you hope I didn't
answer your question yes I think I did
well my best work I think is I don't
know what it is it depends what kind of
work we're talking about if it's realism
if it's fantasy and monster if it's Gore
Johnny our answer yeah we should contact
them are they fans of the channel okay
almost everyone you've worked with is a
big fan of this jam everybody I have the
fan of the real rejects right here they
make up let me ask you some questions
what made you decide to do like to start
your own YouTube channel tool and
interviews with makeup effects are you
sitting around one day and you're like
yeah yeah I'm sick of watching stuff I'd
rather watch myself or watch myself
well actually I've always been a passion
for writing and I did do like a lot of
improv and acting then eventually what I
actually got to like network marketing
too and that learned a lot about
business and then then eventually I was
just working at doctor's office I didn't
really watch YouTube people had always
know you should review movies Greg you
should review movies you review movies
because I love talking films so in the
beginning we had started this up John
and I but he was in college at the time
so then I had to take a lot of my own
hands and then for a few years we were
doing this and I originally did it
because I wanted to do something fun
related I wanted to do something where I
can put some knowledge out there this is
what my real passion is in is in film so
as much as I love commenting on movies
and stuff and I don't really do
interviews I think you can see why I
don't know you good you're relying a lot
on the people that are writing in there
kind of yeah I mean it's because I've
been thinking about you know then you've
got like yeah I mean you know in
facebook and you know back you know
going way back it was like MySpace and
whatever I write now it's because
doesn't YouTube isn't there like a pay
version of that like no they're making
their own content they call the YouTube
premium yeah we're producing their own
projects that is officially ending I
hear which is which is a bummer because
I like some other contact Joe I'm gonna
get you out here just on time I said -
it is - 21 perfect well I'm glad you
finally feel like you can say you've
made it in Hollywood now that you're
here and as Sherman Oaks apartment can't
wait to see the puppet shows I expect
all my move everything out of here by
next week before you go back to working
on the Jungle Cruise movie please
absolutely quick notification bells Joel
as always reject nation we appreciate
you tuning in
and just some great questions I need a
signature sign-off or to have five years
four and a half five years we don't have
a sign-off yet
I'll even catch phrases or you know how
you doing you want people to follow you
anywhere you just want them to go check
out all these uh you know independent
films that you have coming out this year
Oh
follow me I don't really do a lot of
that stuff what I want do you need to do
you like me to I don't know
you know if yeah if it gets tried funded
then yeah okay actually that might that
might be your ticket into getting into
getting funded who here talk for an hour
this is gonna be trimmed it was a
two-parter I don't think any of it
except for the stuff I mentioned earlier
I've managed to make Joel at times feel
slightly awkward I've managed to open up
just two times and I've managed to get
him confused on when I'm being sincere
and sarcastic we'll make this happen
yes all right well I'm looking for your
drama off with Chad Smith and Will
Ferrell see you guys
[Applause]